[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben es gibt wieder mal
etwas mit kinder maxi king ich glaube
ihr habt mittlerweile gemerkt ich liebe
einfach maxi king und heute habe ich für
euch diese leckere maxi king wettert
schnittchen und wir starten jetzt
erstmal mit der zubereitung der böden
und es deckelt dafür benötigen wir zwei
packungen blätterteig 20 gramm
traubenzucker etwas milch und 100 gramm
gehackte haselnüsse für den boden wird
der erste blätterteig auf ein mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech gelegt
und mit einem teig roller noch flacher
gerollt dann werden mit hilfe einer
gabel mehrere löcher in den teig
gestochen von anschließend mit milch
gestrichen
[Musik]
darüber gehen wir jetzt noch die hälfte
des frauen zuckers und dann wird der
boden bei 200 grad ober und unterhitze
15 minuten lang verboten ist der fertige
blätterteig ist an einigen stellen
trotzdem etwas hoch gegangen die stellen
wendet mit einem flachen gegenstand wie
zum beispiel diesen löffel hier einmal
flach gedrückt damit auch alle stellen
gleich hoch sind
[Musik]
und der kommt jetzt zum abkühlen einmal
an die seite für den deckel wird auch
die zweite blätterteig auf dem backblech
ausgerollt diesmal wird nicht mit der
gabel eingestochen sondern direkt die
milch darüber verstrichen
dann werden die haselnüsse unter
restliche braunem zucker darüber
verteilt
[Musik]
anschließend wird er auch bei 200 grad
gebacken und praktika 17 minuten lang
während der blätterteig noch warm ist
wird er schon mal ein stückchen
geschnitten denn wenn er kalt ist
semester sich nicht mehr ganz so gut
durchschneiden
ich habe mich hier für zwölf stücke
entschieden
[Musik]
jetzt widmen wir uns den leckeren
inneren dafür machen wir erst die
karamell themen die besteht aus 200
gramm ps 75 gramm braunem 75 gramm
weißen zucker und 50 milliliter sahne
zuallererst werden creme fraiche und
zucker in einer pfanne gegeben und gut
miteinander vermengen
danach ständig die pfanne auf den herd
und erhitzte das ganze bitte anfängt zu
kochen
anfangs darf man ruhig ein bisschen
umrühren hinterher sollte das ganze aber
einfach nur vor sich hin köcheln
optimaler weise wie das ganze jetzt auf
120 grad erhitzt wer kein thermometer
habt ihr letztes kämpfe einfach drei
minuten lang köcheln
dann kann sie auch schon runter vom herd
noch einmal kräftig durchrühren die
sahne hinzufügen noch mal alles
miteinander vermischen und jetzt muss
ich vollständig abkühlen gibt's da
einfach für 30 minuten in den
gefrierschrank
desweiteren benötigen wir für die sahne
füllung 600 milliliter kalte schlagsahne
500 gramm mascarpone 12 teelöffel
sommerbad zwei teelöffel vanille extrakt
und 20 milliliter karamell sirup der ist
meiner meinung nach unverzichtbar denn
er macht den unterschied im geschmack
und ist auch gar nicht mal so teuer ich
habe diesmal den ausprobiert für 1 eur
960 schaut einfach was euch euer
supermarkt anbietet
zuerst wird die kalte seine ca 30
sekunden lang vermisst dann gebe ich
sechs zähler für sonderfahrten vor und
schlage das ganze komplett steiß
die sonne kommt dann erst mal in die
füllung so lange mache ich mit der macht
capone weiter die gebe ich zusammen mit
leben vanille extrakt und dem karamell
sirup in die schüssel und vermisse das
einmal
[Musik]
dann gebe ich noch die restlichen sechs
zähler für seiner park mit hinzu und
vermisste das noch mal und da seht ihr
auch das fixing schon viel verliert zum
schluss wird die sahne untergehoben und
dann ist die leckere themen füllung auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
auf dem blätterteig boden wird nun die
hälfte der mascarpone sahne creme
verteilt
[Musik]
darüber gebe ich dann die komplette
karamell creme wichtig ist nur dass die
komplett ausgekühlt ist die garantin
wird dann mit der rückseite eines
löffels komplett verstrichen
[Musik]
und darüber wird dann die zweite creme
der mast ab ohne sahne creme gegeben und
noch einmal schön bleibt verstrichen
[Musik]
obendrauf werden dann noch die haselnuss
blätterteig decke gelegt
so die deko habe ich 80 gramm
geschmolzene kuvertüre in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt und die spitze
abgeschnitten und die kuvertüre wird
dann gründlich auf dem deckel verteilt
und was das auf keinen fall fehlen
natürlich kinder maxi king stückchen
[Musik]
wenn ihr dann alles schön verteilt habt
dann sind die blätterteig maxime
schnittchen auch schon sofort fertig zum
verzehr
und hier ist noch mal das leckere
endergebnisse in seiner vollen pracht es
ist so lecker eine warnung habe ich noch
wenn du ein stück davon ist dann hast du
das gefühl das geht nicht da muss noch
ein stück gegessen werden
denn das liegt auch überhaupt nicht
schwer im magen superlecker wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und freue
mich natürlich über euer feedback über
kommentare über ein abo und ich sag bis
zum nächsten mal auf die kids kitchen